hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and um
i'm just checking in on you
i'm just checking in on you seeing how
your work week's going
how things in your life are are are
doing
i'll be honest with you i used to just
check in on you now i just do these
podcasts cause i'm bored out of my
[ __ ] mind
jesus christ roy i'm bored with it
i can't stop speaking in a [ __ ]
english accent ever since i was
going to sleep my wife was watching that
royal interview
oh my god she had it on like [ __ ]
full blast
i really think oprah winfrey is like the
king of doing interviews
about [ __ ] that everybody already knew
so when she did the lance armstrong
thing like wait a minute
you telling me those people who rode
bicycles up and down mountains for a
month
were on drugs what
right so you're saying that some of the
richest white people on the earth that
live in a castle in
england are racist
i know you need to get the information
out there but the look of shock
oh it's like you don't need to sell it
that old [ __ ] stupid goddamn
i mean how many examples do you need
how many guys in the [ __ ] bike race
got busted every [ __ ] one of them got
busted for [ __ ] being on drugs
um anyway right so it's out at a club
right
all of a sudden this ginger [ __ ] comes
up to me he's like roy
i'm a prince i'm like what he's like
yeah
i'm like you're a prince prince of war
he's like prince of england
i'm like yeah he's like yeah i'm like
what
i'm like right get away from me you
[ __ ] red [ __ ]
and he's like right i live in a castle
i'm like well he's like yeah i live in a
castle i'm like what kind of castle he's
like
a castle castle
so i got me knickers in a bunch so i go
over there
right he opens the door
there's someone with a yak head on his
head
[ __ ] a maid i'm like what's that he's
like oh that's me die
he's having a laugh and i was like what
i'm out of here
hey look at me he said i live in a
castle
i said all right keep going
so we walked down the hall
right and all these old white ladies are
giving me a look
like there's something wrong with me
they're like right why isn't she wearing
a made uniform
i was like well he's like pay him no
mind
pay him she's with me she's with me
right nana she's with me
enough
so we walk into the jewelry room he's
like right pick something out
it was a little i can't do it i can't
i can't keep going with this
you know all she needed to do when she
grew up is if she watched a couple of
episodes of dallas
i mean look how [ __ ] crazy those
people act acted and they were just in
texas they didn't have a castle
they had a ranch that's how white people
behave when they have a ranch
like what do you think's gonna happen
when they have a castle in a fleet of
yachts
harry harry was the rebel right
his brother was the one they loved oh
come head
hear the colorless sun
he's going to be the next king right so
harry
he's already red he's already angry
he's like right [ __ ] it
so he walks up to me he says hello
i'm like hello i don't know why she has
an english accent
i just can't stop hearing that stupid
accent
you poor awaken i said no i'm not
and he goes oh sorry i'm like right [ __ ]
off
[ __ ] off you go he's like right i live
in a castle
and i was like go on
so we're at royal albert hall in a
private box
i'm thinking about offering myself
i can't listen to another person play a
cello
um anyway
i find a lot what she said very
relatable
grew up in a toxic environment you know
i kind of related to a lot of that stuff
except i did it in a duplex
um right so we're like these people
are evil these are evil white
people let's move to where the open
white people
are in santa barbara
roy where i can see
people who look like me doing gardening
for the white people in santa barbara oh
there's oprah
she had this [ __ ] thing on
full blast oh my god i was [ __ ]
i was kill i can't remember the [ __ ] i
was saying
at one point i i actually got near to
stop listening to the interview
when she was dying laughing and i was
going just being the the woman there
right going like don't you think that's
a little unfair
he's like well i said it's unfair
he's like right what that mean he's like
what what what me
he says unfair what that word meat never
heard it
sorry all right so i've just been
walking around
for the i woke up this morning i do my
dodo and i went downstairs in my
in the basement and uh i don't know what
happened
everything we had some sort of fly nest
down there house flies
big [ __ ] right and they must have
been down there for a little bit
because they they weren't that hard to
hit you know
i mean i was killing two at a time with
the old fly swatter
talking [ __ ] the whole time you know
i actually apologize to a spider that's
how many fire flies i killed
like sorry man you think your legs are
skinny now
i just took your whole [ __ ] food
supply but i'm leaving you
i'm leaving you because i think there's
one left and that's for you and then you
kill it
and then you eat it okay
and then the the next part of the story
is up to you
you got six [ __ ] legs you got six
ways to hop
skip whatever gallop your way the [ __ ]
out of my house
or i'm coming for you tomorrow you got
it
he was like right good show
right so then they're serving tea and
crumpets
i was like walt says he says it's a
crumpet so i took out me hot sauce i put
it on there he's like right what you
doing
said i'm adding some flavor he's like i
think you brought enough flavor already
if you know what i mean
know what i mean nudge nudge know what i
mean
um anyway
oh [ __ ] so i woke up this morning boo
doo doo doo doo and i was like you know
what i'm going to do
i i need to uh i got to get rid of this
you know this covered weight that i i i
ended up putting on
um and uh
i got something this weekend it's an
awards show
right and i have to wear a suit so
i got my white suit that fits that's my
that's my me tauren suit
yeah um
that's my touring suit so that's like me
when i'm just walking around wait but
then i got two other suits one's the
suit i got married in
and the other one is the suit uh that i
i
got tailored when i was in acting shape
which is about a buck 68 so i'm like 178
now
all right 10 pounds over a couple of
stone
whatever the [ __ ] stone is a couple
of pebbles
um so i went in to try on
the [ __ ] the actor in shape suit and
dude when i tell you i was missing it by
[ __ ] three and a half inches
around the waist and i was like well i
was like you got to be [ __ ] kidding
me
and then i looked at the the the and
then i take out the wedding suit
black suit i'm like okay that's good for
an award show black suit white shirt
black tie cool
right and as i'm putting it on i was
like dude you wore this at your wedding
there's no way you're gonna couldn't
make it i was like god damn it
so i had to go buy a suit i had to go
buy a suit so
i went down there it's [ __ ] hilarious
you know anytime if you go
out go to go buy a nice suit i don't
give a [ __ ] what's what shape you're in
they're gonna make you feel like you're
[ __ ]
50 pounds overweight they're like yeah
it looks good in the shoulders let's see
the pants i'm like i can't get in those
[ __ ] things
and we'll let them out a little bit i go
why don't we go up to the next size
yeah it's not going to look as good it's
like
how the [ __ ] is somebody going to notice
the next size
when was the last time you had on a pair
of 34 jeans and then
next day you know you came in with a
pair of 36 and somebody just looked at
you like
did you go up a couple of inches
so anyway but it motivated me so now i'm
gonna try to get back
i'm already doing this [ __ ] so i'm i'm
gonna try to get back down
i'm gonna get back down right so i gotta
go to the grocery store today buy some
more uh
kind of the root vegetables man and
these buddha bowls
sorry sorry right he called it a buddha
bow
i'm like that's offensive he's like
right what that mean never heard that
word
what do you mean you never heard that
i live in a castle what going to cast
a castle castle with jewelry
and servants
oh that was the joke i said
i was like roy i'm going to go fox
hunting million
dogs i was like don't you think that's a
little unfair
you say walked out mate unfair never
heard the word
anyway so i woke up this morning
to try to get uh myself i was gonna go
on a hike
and uh i don't i don't know if you got
kids i don't give a [ __ ] what time you
get up they're up
and all you got to do is step out one
piece of wood one creaking wood piece of
wood my
lovely daughter comes up i got all the
way down the stairs i'm like oh my god i
did it
i did it then i'm a dad so i'm turning
off the outside lights right jesus
christ you think i'm made out of light
bulbs
right i'm doing that [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
shutting off the lights
and um right as i'm slipping on my
second sneaker
i hear her little innocent voice daddy
i look up like hey buddy
can i go wake up mommy i'm like nope
that's not a good idea don't do that
she's like um um can can you um um can
you
can you i'm like what buddy
i'm gonna go on a hike here she goes
okay okay but um
can you make me pancakes
right she's got a little pajamas on
she's got the bed head going
i'm like all right okay buddy come on
downstairs she goes thanks dada
can i help my guy go get the step stool
okay
and it did the whole thing i made her
some pancakes so then i didn't go i
haven't gone so i weighed myself this
morning 178.6 now i was up to 183.
so um you know that's a good
you know it's good i'm down like five
pounds here but
uh i'm kind of all out of my healthy
food so i gotta go buy some today and i
gotta i gotta cook
and just have that [ __ ] ready because
that is the [ __ ] key
to losing weight is you have to not only
eat well but you gotta have your feet
your feet you have to have your food
prepared
because if you don't then the demons
take over let's go get a sandwich come
on have somebody else
make it steak and cheese oh
yeah and then immediately you're just
thinking all that salty goodness that
you're gonna have you're like well i
gotta take the edge off after that
little pine ice cream
huh little cookies and cream vanilla
bean know what i mean
um so
yeah so i'm just kind of uh
i'm working on that um
i just this is just one of these deals
like the way i'm eating if there was a
gym
in my life if i just could get on an
elliptical
um right what's that it's a cardio
machine
never heard of it what's called warts
cardio
don't you just do a shot of virgin blood
um sorry a little ginger
um yeah be coming off but then i always
go back to like bill
if you just walk outside and start
walking up hills that's a free cardio
machine
you dumb [ __ ] right just go do that so
that's what i was planning on doing this
morning but it didn't quite work out
because uh because i got my priorities
straight
you know um
so anyway got to get another covid test
today uh old freckles is gonna be on the
grammys on sunday if you can believe it
can't sing a lick of music right
and uh i'm gonna be a presenter too so i
have to have a suit you gotta you gotta
you gotta look right
you know like i almost didn't wear a
suit for that critics choice awards for
uh judd apatows and pete davidson's
movie king of staten island and thank
god i did
when i saw like i was saying when i saw
donald sutherland and he was wearing a
tux with a black tie
i was like they're raised right right
there
you got to you got to be clashy
you got to be classy all right so i'm
going to starve myself until sunday
no i'm not i'm just going to keep i'm
going to go on hike so i'm going the
other way right
i'm just going to keep eating healthy
and keep [ __ ] moving
so i don't i don't pop a button on me
jacket
off me trousers off me knickers um
but anyways did you guys see the new uh
b.i.g notorious b.i.g whatever you're
supposed to call him
it was biggie smalls and it turned out
the first biggie smalls was a white guy
huh black people always say white people
are stealing from you
evidently huh it goes the other way
the first biggie smalls was a white guy
you
you guys stole the name from him that
that innocent white guy
rapping took your music
um
so i watched the whole i was watching
that whole thing man it was a just an
amazing documentary uh
i was talking to verzi about it on the
uh
anything better podcast and just like
that guy had like 50 years of wisdom by
the time he was 20.
such a brilliant brilliant mind man such
a brilliant mind
and then i thought like what he was up
against i thought they were they just i
don't know i don't know anything about
hip-hop but they just come off
like uh like idiots not idiots they they
act like 20-something-year-olds
and now that whole [ __ ] thing
escalated
um i don't know
[ __ ] waste man what a giant [ __ ]
waste of talent on both sides
with that whole thing but uh so many
similarities
in his story i just kept thinking about
patrice i'm like jesus christ this guy
was the same thing patrice was like a
[ __ ] it's like talking to a 70 year
old man when he was like 24
25 you know but he still had that
silliness to him but like
could really have a [ __ ] deep
conversation
um i always wondered like what that was
about when you meet people like that
is it like the brain they were born with
plus their experience it's got to be
that it's got to be that
or is it their experience i don't think
it is because you can meet somebody in
the exact same experience
has had the exact same experience and
they're [ __ ] you know
dumb as a stump whatever the [ __ ]
expression is
but um
i don't know like i even thought when
you saw him with like his whole crew it
was like he was the uh
he was like the dad it wasn't like he
was like the leader
he just came off like like you know
the older guy like 20 he seemed like he
was 20 years beyond his whole crew of
people
and helping them stay out of trouble and
all of that [ __ ]
um really really fascinating documentary
and i started to watch another philip
seymour hoffman movie
kind of going down that rabbit hole
something mahoney i just started to
watch it and then my wife saw us
watching it and she was just like oh i
want to watch that with you and i was
like all right but we never we never got
around to it
so um anyway i got a
got a couple more uh shows this weekend
i'm getting geared up today
today today i believe today one of these
days coming up if you can believe it
um i'm going to be doing a tour
of new zealand in all of
australia
it's going to be one show if you can
believe this
and i'm doing it from los angeles
this is like one of the great things
that came out of
the pandemic is that i rather than
having to
as far as environment environmentally
that's a word instead of me jumping on a
jet
you know polluting the sky and doing all
of that [ __ ] i can just do it from here
which is really cool but i got to get
ready for the show but
um as much as i would love
because new zealand and australia were
two of the most beautiful most beautiful
beaches
i've ever seen in my life were in
australia
and um and same thing in like new
zealand it's just like there's a reason
why
they shoot all those nerd movies down
there i mean part of it is because
there's no
sag in new zealand and then they don't
have to pay the actors ever again that's
a different story
but just the way that it looks
is um
you know when we were in new zealand one
time the only time we went there
we went to some beach and the sand was
like all black there was this giant like
mountain on one side and like the
greenest
foliage ever and you're like this
right here looks like exactly how it
looked
when the first boatload of evil white
people showed up
i felt like an explorer like christopher
columbus that's how beautiful it was
and i was waiting for like you know
indigenous people to come out from
behind the bushes
just looking at me like what's your deal
and then i could be like roy
i'm the guy who's about ready to [ __ ]
all this up
um but anyway so i'm gonna be doing
a a stand-up show and uh
i can't even [ __ ] tell you how
excited i am to do this
and how [ __ ] hard i'm gonna go
on this show okay
people have been i did i did that
benefit
show you know same same place i did this
benefit show where they had the uh you
know the screens and all of that
and i just got such a uh
it's the energy that you get even
standing on the screen just seeing the
people
that sit in their apartments and they
like make like an evening out of it they
make some food they're sitting down
there's a lot of dates and stuff
and i think when you're on in front of a
live crowd obviously you get that
amazing energy but like
you kind of don't get the back story you
can get like the backstory oh look at
this person one bedroom apartment
you know young couple they got their
whole lives ahead of them you just get
it's like
you're peeking in on all these little
reality shows and they have their names
down the bottom
you know you could talk to them and [ __ ]
it's
uh it's oddly
as distant as it is the distance that's
it's really like an
intimate thing and they just sort of
keep changing the screens there's three
screens so at any
given time there's like 150 people there
um you know
but i'm really really excited about it
and uh al del benny
one of my favorite people in this
business i started with him
way back in the day i met him on
my second or third show ever definitely
my third show
when i did kelly's in in uh reading or
north reading mass
first time i ever bomped i did nick's
comedy stop
then i did an open mic at stitches and
then i did
uh jack lynch a had a satellite open mic
room
in this bar up in north reading and i
ate my balls
and he was hosting and i met him and he
used to have a sketch group called alan
the monkeys
with uh bobby kelly
dane cook him and this guy
jay i forget his name i forget his name
but he ended up stopped doing comedy but
became like a real estate kingpin so he
made it too which is awesome
um
anyway so i've known him for almost 30
years
and whenever i do australia because he
he ended up meeting an australian woman
in new york
long story short he's over there now and
uh so whenever i do australia i try to
you know i try and work with him if he's
not uh
you know if he doesn't have other gigs
so
that's gonna be the show so i should
have a ticket link and all of that stuff
i thought i was gonna have it today
um i don't see it in the reads here but
uh i will
be posting that on my twitter and
instagram
as soon as possible and uh i'm very
excited my apologies to
people in new zealand and australia that
i i can't go there because
um you know i would have loved to go on
as much as that that
that that [ __ ] that run always beats
the [ __ ] out of me
because it's just that the time change
and it's just right as i get acclimated
right as i get acclimated i'm like oh my
god this is great
i'm on their time i can enjoy this
beautiful country
i can go to new zealand enjoy this blah
blah blah right as i do that it's like
okay now you're going back um
i actually had i had it down too how i
would do it when i would fly to
australia my move was
i would take the 4pm flight
and uh i'd sit there and i would
[ __ ] with my wife and we'd always be
laughing and being
excited um
and whenever i have like something
really long in front of me like that a
14-hour flight
i get in a really stupid mood and
uh and one of my favorite things in the
world is making my wife laugh right
so i just start making her laugh makes
her feel good i feel good
then uh you know we have all these
snacks and [ __ ] we're just like
[ __ ] it right we just go to the airport
just bring all this
[ __ ] you know stupid [ __ ] right
to eat
candy and [ __ ] potato chips and just
[ __ ] it let's just eat like we're in
seventh grade right
and then we get like a meal and then i
watch
two movies and then by then it's like
about one in the morning and then i fall
asleep
and at that point you're like five hours
into flight and then i fall asleep for
like eight hours
and then you wake up and it's like you
know we've begun our initial descent
into australia everybody's gonna have
the same accent on this podcast
and then you land you're like wow this
is amazing and you're like okay i feel
good
it felt good you lie to yourself that
you're on
australian time and then right around
like one or two in the afternoon it just
[ __ ] hits you and then you go
down hard and then you wake up
and you're like [ __ ] and it's like 8 30
at night and you woke up like it's 8 30
in the morning and then you just got to
fight that
i've i've done those gigs a few times
with dom herrera and he has like the
most interesting way
of dealing with jet lag he goes you know
i just don't fight it i just
i just go to sleep and i'll stay up all
night i don't give a [ __ ] and i'll just
and he's totally okay with like waking
up
having like something to eat like his
breakfast
and then just literally walking out and
going on stage
um it's an amazing thing i was just like
wow that's sort of the way to do it i
think
i don't know i always try and fight it
but there's a i have a lot of memories
of being in europe and australia
trying to stay awake i remember the
first time we went to stockholm sweden
we stayed at the burn hotel
um it was sort of some story they were
telling us about some american rock
singer we had some hissy fit in there
and
threw something down like [ __ ] idiot
but i remember
clearly sitting outside the burn hotel
they had like a little plaza there where
you could eat
and like just trying to be out in the
cold air
and the sunlight trying to stay awake me
and my
beautiful wife man she looks so great on
that trip i remember that when i
bought some clothes and stuff i still
remember her face we were just sitting
there
and we were just like okay i'm staying
up right we're staying i'm staying up
staying up and we lasted about 20
minutes and i was just like nene i can't
do this she goes all right let's just
let's just go to sleep and they had like
blackout curtains and
we went in there and uh
oh my god this i have so many [ __ ]
memories of doing that in europe and we
would just [ __ ] go to sleep
and then wake up it would be like seven
or eight o'clock at night you're like ah
[ __ ] all right just give yourself a
couple of days we'll get acclimated
and she was always better at it than i
was
um doing that man i we they got to cure
this [ __ ] soon people i hope people take
the vaccine
i miss doing all of that stuff um all
right let me do some reads here
roy live in a castle all right oh man oh
max
oh max cryofreeze oh i'm an old bastard
i love this [ __ ]
living with chronic pain is the worst
not as bad as living in a castle uh it's
more than a
it's a more more wait it's more than a
feeling of discomfort it can affect your
whole life
many of my listeners probably have some
time some type of pain
that has prevented them from relaxing
and sleeping
or stopped them from exercising jesus
this is like written for me here perhaps
it's been ongoing for a few weeks and
now hasn't improved with any of the
treatments
they've tried podcast host to provide an
experience of recent pain oh my left
shoulder
but i've been using this [ __ ] and then
working out with bands and now my
shoulder feels great
enter omax health roy
if you're looking to get rid of nagging
muscle and joint pain
immediately while providing long-lasting
recovery by the way all the english
people are gonna tell me i'm doing a bad
english accent it's as bad as your
american accent that you think is so
[ __ ] brilliant
uh then you need to try the natural
breakthrough pain relief solution
cryofreeze
cbd roll-on developed by omax health
this
non-prescription triple action uh
pain relief roll-on is specially
formulated to block pain receptors
reduce inflammation and improve muscle
and joint flexibility the best part is
this is a 100 natural cbd powdered
powered remedy that works its magic
within 10 minutes of application relief
lasts up to eight hours much longer than
the over-the-counter
uh products um
yeah this is the stuff i put on my
shoulder after i work out every single
time and now i don't have any nagging
pain
uh you do this [ __ ] you work out with
some bands i'm telling you you get get
a personal trainer to tell you how to
work out with them okay you don't need a
lawsuit here all right
all right cta i don't know what that
means omax health is offering my
listeners 20
off a full bottle of cryofreeze cbd
pain relief roll this discount also
applies towards any products
site-wide just go to omaxhealth.com
today and enter the code bur
that is omax health.com and enter the
code bur
b-u-r-r to get 20 off cryo-freeze and
site-wide
still not sold i can tell you pro
athletes such as pga pro golfer kyle
stanley
uses cryo-free cbd to recover both on
and off the course
and go look at the product reviews
they've got
95 5 star reviews page after page of
customers
saying they tried everything and omax
cryofreeze is so good they are now
buying it for their family and friends
too
anyone from athletes to grandma josie
can benefit from this
immediate pain relief uh you have pain
that won't go away then you qualify for
omex cryo fees
freeze simply roll it over where it
hurts and ice out the pain no messy
creams or any of that [ __ ] so go to
omax
uh health.com and enter the code burr
to get 20 off cryofreeze sitewise omax
health.com
enter the code bird and get 20 off i
don't know why this made me think of
this
but i watched this video on youtube of
paul stanley
singing a song you know with kiss live
some [ __ ] you know explosion goes off
and his hair catches on fire
starts off small and then just gets big
and then these roadies run out
trying to put it out and when i tell you
he didn't flinch and just kept playing
the song
and he knew what was happening there's
no way he didn't smell it
it was [ __ ] amazing first of all
that he like the show goes on you never
stop
the fact i mean that man lives by a code
and then
secondly that he has such faith in his
[ __ ] roadies he's literally his
[ __ ] head is on fire
and he says still say yeah they got it
don't worry it just kept going
didn't miss the neck lick didn't [ __ ]
miss a chord change
it's incredible um candid
uh are you unhappy with your smile you
don't have to be
are your teeth a little crooked yeah
thousands of people have used candid the
clear comfortable removable and
practically invisible aligners to help
straighten their teeth
and now they love their smile just like
justin
m atlanta georgia when i was younger i
used to have a gap in my front
and on the side i noticed that people
would always look at my mouth first
it's probably because you were spitting
on them so i was looking for a fix
candid ended up being the perfect
company for me
you can't stop me from smiling now i
don't give a [ __ ] that people think i'm
crazy
i'm not spitting on them anymore there's
no comparison i added a little to that
and candid is here to help straighten
your teeth
so you can fall in love with your smile
too your treatment is prescribed and
closed
closely monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement you'll
have the same
quality of care you'd get from an
in-office orthodontist from the comfort
and convenience of your
own home and while other companies use
general dentists candid
candid only works with orthodontist with
candid the same orthodontist who created
your plan
is with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start to
you'll start seeing results way before
that and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces
become your best you start straightening
your teeth today right now you can save
dollars on candidate starter kit go to
candid co
charlie oscar candidco.com
and use the code bird that's
candidco.com
codebird take advantage of oh so it's
slash burr
then code bur all right take advantage
of this limited time offer to save 75
dollars on your first start
on your starter kit candidco.com
all right the last one everybody helix
everybody
you know not being able to sleep
because of today's politics pandemics
your love life
any of the drama you talk about in your
show
um slash all of that [ __ ] uh sleeping on
a terrible mattress before you upgraded
to helix that's a fragment
sleeping on a terrible mattress before
you upgraded to helix yeah well that's
the end of that idea
what happened helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body
type and sleep preference to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're going you're getting a
mattress that you know will be the
perfect way
to help you sleep everybody's unique
everybody's unique
and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress
models to choose from well then aren't
they saying there's only a few kinds of
people
what are you acting like you see you got
like every mattress is different like a
snowflake maybe it is
maybe it is they have soft medium and
firm mattresses just like goldilocks and
the three bears
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
jesus christ and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size folks
it's been awesome getting messages from
so many people who also find the helix
mattress of their dreams
uh so if you're looking for a mattress
you take a quiz
you order the mattress that you're
matched to the mattress comes right to
your door
ship for free you don't ever need to go
to a mattress store again and they're
doing all these new studies by the way
they're talking about dementia and
alzheimer's and all that
and one of the big things that helps you
know uh plaque not build up in your
brain they're saying
is to get enough sleep and enough rest
and this is a great way to do it this is
a great investment
so you don't have to [ __ ] walk around
not remembering you know like me not
knowing where [ __ ] is
all right so uh if you're looking for a
mattress
i already said that uh helix is awesome
but you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
uh by gq and wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com
all right that's the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
please please enjoy the the little bit
of music here musical interlude
picked out by the wonderful andrew
themless um
and then we're gonna have uh a bonus
half hour episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast from uh thursday
morning podcast
from a couple years ago however he does
it all right that's it
right so what's the lesson
if you find some ginger [ __ ] in a boss
who says well i live in a castle
i guess don't go in it if you do go with
it
and you want to like you know just sort
of decompress from all the horrible [ __ ]
that you saw in there
you want to go to santa barbara
because that's where the open-minded
white people live all right
i'll talk to you have a great weekend
i'll talk to you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
march 11 2013 how you doing
how's your life working out for you this
week
i um i had a oh jesus you know what i
can't even tell you what happened
i i can't tell it i have to sing it to
you it's gotta come from my heart
oh if you're a lucky man good things
happen to you
but if you're a red [ __ ] this is
for the [ __ ] zoo you'll be out on the
road and find out your roof collapsed
and there won't be a thing you can do
about it
that make any sense i don't care if it
did you know most of some of the biggest
hits never made any sense
right ah suga
you are my candy girl
um so i was touring the midwest
barnstorming as they say driving in some
no-name dodge suv
you know that's what you get when you
say hey i want to rent
a car from madison wisconsin to detroit
michigan and i don't want to bring it
back do you have a car for me and they
say oh wow you know what i think we got
one here in the back
i didn't even know dodge made an suv you
know
dodge is like the oldsmobile of chrysler
um oldsmobiles are nice i'd like you
know i miss all those cars
remember the oldsmobile remember people
had a mercury
what else do they discontinue pontiacs
what has happened to this country what
are we about to down to either chevy or
a cadillac that's [ __ ] it
ford or a lincoln go [ __ ] yourself you
know you either have it or you don't
once again another sign of the middle
class shrinking
um oh by the way you know i just found
out you know because i don't pay
attention to politics anymore because i
just feel like all right you know
they're they're eventually just they're
going to run it to the ground we have to
build it back up again that's that's
basically what's going to happen
i guess so uh old uh [ __ ] liberal
face there he signed that thing new
year's eve
basically passing off that now they can
just arrest you and detain you
without a trial forever that's good
there you go
see that right there people remember
when you all made fun of me because i
don't vote for the [ __ ]
number one horse or number two horse
that's why because there's no difference
it's the same [ __ ] horse
oh shut up bill all right so this is
what happened
so i'm [ __ ] driving this no name
dodge driving this dodge suv
i'm in madison wisconsin and
about ready to do all these awesome
shows i love going to towns like that by
the way
i can tell you this unbelievably
underrated is
cities that uh frank sinatra did not
sing about
[Laughter]
you know or tony bennett any any crooner
if a crooner
has sung about a city then you can tell
right away that you know
before you even land on the ground
there's going to be ridiculous traffic
and everything's going to cost
twice as much you know my kind of town
chicago is eighty dollars for a
hamburger
chicago is that [ __ ] loop
where no traffic [ __ ] moves why
did we come here right
i left my heart in san francisco
that in your [ __ ] wallet there and
then new york you know what that is
right
bunch of [ __ ] losers with stenciled
goatees and sweatpants thinking they're
[ __ ]
they're they're making it if i can wake
up in a city right and they're sitting
there shirtless riding in a [ __ ] hugo
that they cut the roof off of putting
their hands in the air as they drive
through [ __ ] times square making a
video for their rockabilly album
you know all of those places i'm not
saying you shouldn't go there you should
definitely go there right
and bring your easel and do a little
sketch or whatever the [ __ ] it is you're
supposed to do
but i'm telling you don't sleep on
madison wisconsin
don't you dare look down on milwaukee
wisconsin and i'll tell you right now i
got another one for you this is the
uppercut
grand rapids michigan yeah where are you
guys going on vacation you going to
puerto rico
you going to acapulco no we're going to
grand rapids michigan
and we're going to get some [ __ ] i'm
going to go get a waffle witch at the uh
the real
food cafe
i ate like a [ __ ] suicidal plumber
this week
at least the breakfast is i had a waffle
witch when i was in grand rapids
michigan
oh royal oak michigan i also forgot
about that
and i'll tell you downtown detroit's
slowly coming back the outskirts are
still pretty scary but i gotta tell you
you know they have pockets
you know there's a gleam gentleman there
is a gleam
worst [ __ ] pre-playoff
i think i talked about that speech ever
marty schottenheimer
he's trying to get his team amped up to
win a playoff game they're standing on
that [ __ ] football weather where you
can see your breath
you know and as they're looking at his
breath in his breath it says
there's a cleave gentleman there is a
gleam
a gleam a gleam has never been spoken in
football ever
you know if you in fact if you have a
gleam i think at this point that's one
of the reasons why you get cut from a
football team
why did you get why did you get rid of
him i thought he was doing all right on
our special teams ah there was a gleam
it was a gleam gentleman and i didn't
like it i didn't see that killer
instinct
he was too gleamy yes this podcast isn't
going to make any sense because my
[ __ ] brain is all over the place
because i have a hole in the roof of my
house
i will get to that okay i will get to
that and you will sit and you will wait
kind sir
so anyways i am in madison wisconsin
you know and uh i was working with nate
craig and he's from that neck of the
woods
actually grew up right near there so he
was taking me around town went to all
these great places to eat went to this
some legendary breakfast place
one of those greasy spoons that
somebody's running for president stops
in at
you know has two bites of eggs does a
thumbs up with some [ __ ]
immigrant wearing an apron and then he
leaves well i actually stayed there
i ate the whole breakfast and i'm not
running for anything you know
um
oh god i'm so fat right now
you can't believe how smooth my stomach
is
my stomach right now is so [ __ ]
smooth you wouldn't even believe that i
could sit up in bed because you would
say that poor bastard was born without
abdomens abs abdominals there's the
[ __ ] word
so anyways um we do the gig
we do the gig uh what the [ __ ] was it i
don't even know anymore is it thursday
thursday friday saturday
no wednesday we do the gig wednesday we
have a great [ __ ] time
after the gig this guy from the weary
traveler in
rest slash restaurant tells us to come
by we go over there
i look on the menu what do they have on
the menu they have hungarian goulash
when was the last time you ever saw a
hungarian
[ __ ] goulash or the rated g version
hungarian goulash on
on a menu huh well if you do then you
live
in one of these [ __ ] towns that frank
never sung about
and i was like my mother used to make
hungarian goulash i got it i got to try
it
um then i guess when my mother made it
when my mother when she made it she put
noodles in it but this was the i guess
that that the noodles came in
in ellis island which evidently meant
the hungarians were near the italians
and they were like oh
what you got in the pot there you know
what you need step aside once you put
some [ __ ] noodles in there right
there
and right there is it dano
so anyways i had this this cup of uh
if you're in madison wisconsin go i'm
going to hype all these [ __ ]
restaurants
go to the weary traveler in and try a
cup or get yourself a bowl of the
hungarian goulash it's
[ __ ] tremendous it's got a nice kick
to it you know
i visited a couple of old friends you
know
with ice on them and i had a great time
and uh you know great mix of people
there we talked conspiracy theory we
talked about west
welker getting traded you know
we had an awesome [ __ ] time so
everything's going great
you know i'm breathing in the winter air
looking at the dirty snow
i'm feeling good i'm feeling like
nothing can touch me my life
is gonna be phenomenal all right
now the next thing that happened on this
trip is so [ __ ] traumatic
i don't really remember when it started
i believe i was coming out of that
greasy diner
that i'm sure joe biden has eaten it um
and when the pancakes are delicious ha
ha ha
click picture taken he's out forces
himself to puke
in the in the uh taxpayers bus that he's
driving around in
um anyways
the lovely nia calls me up and she's in
absolute tears
all right we had just done redone her
office
redid the floors i swear to god dude it
looked like a [ __ ] basketball court
in there
a very small basketball court you know
if you were like a [ __ ] uh squirrel
it would look like a full court
basketball court to you all right but
whatever i'm just saying
it was [ __ ] beautiful we did the
walls they even painted the ceiling
it was the one room in my old ass
[ __ ] house that was immaculate
all right i just got the roof done
listeners of the podcast realized i just
got the roof done so i'm psyched
okay because two things you don't want
in your [ __ ] house you don't want
fire
and you don't want water nothing does
damage like that
it's just it's [ __ ] over
so she calls me up crying and says the
[ __ ] ceiling collapsed in the office
and there's water pouring in
i'm and i am in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere
wisconsin i was in between somewhere
between madison
and milwaukee and i get this picture and
i get this phone call
and i'm immediately frantic
and i was like has the water stopped
because i guess it rained that night and
i'm like because the water stopped and
i'm thinking we just put a new roof on
it did they [ __ ] up the roof what the
[ __ ] happened a zillion things are going
through my head
how long was the water pouring in
because it happened when she was
sleeping
and then she goes no it stopped and then
she went back in she goes no it started
again
and i was like [ __ ] and you know she was
talking about her pictures and [ __ ] and
i'm like no the floors the [ __ ] rest
of the house get
i wish i thought to tell her to push the
[ __ ] couch
got this stupid ikea couch you know when
you're not thinking you're just trying
to get the furniture out of the way
[ __ ] [ __ ] the couch
let the couch be a giant [ __ ] sponge
um well whatever i was in the middle of
nowhere and uh what ended up happening
was it wasn't the roof
i have a crawl space between my ceiling
and the roof and there was some you know
my house is like 90 years old so there
was some sort of
part of the drainage things one of the
joints failed
it backed up on the side of the house
and the water came up and then one of
the joints failed and then it just
started to pool it sunk down through the
wood and then
you know made the plaster wet and then
it collapsed
and um she didn't hear it collapsed
because it kind of hit the couch was
also [ __ ]
soaking wet and uh the damage was done
and it went all the way down to the
bottom of my [ __ ] house
and my house looks like a disaster right
now
uh but i gotta say the insurance company
did step
up once they realized that it wasn't the
roofers fault
and that it was a plumbing issue or
whatever i don't know what the [ __ ] they
said
um they have stepped up and they came
over here
[ __ ] help the lovely neil clean up
they put some fans on it but by then the
[ __ ] damage was done so
i don't know what's going to happen i'm
absolutely sick right now
because they're trying to tell me that
the floor buckled
um and i immediately pictured all the
floorboards just
every one of them just [ __ ] looking
like hammer toes but
i think they're trying to say it's in
the middle of the room i don't know what
but that wood is priceless you know
that's the wood that they from trees
they cut down in the 20s that were you
know old trees
when wood was solid men were men and
women didn't have a voice
now you got that home depot [ __ ] you
know i should make as much as you
kind of would right so
that's my big fear is that they're going
to take out that wood and replace it
with the other ship
so i've already put the kybosh on that
and i'm like listen
uh insurance peoples that's the kind of
wood that was there and that's the kind
of wood that's gonna be put
down if i have to [ __ ] scour the
earth to find it if i have to go to
detroit and go into one of those
abandoned [ __ ] crack house beautiful
hundred-year-old [ __ ]
houses and take the wood out myself i am
ah i don't want to get into it it's
[ __ ] horrible my brother's coming out
to visit
you know he's visiting me like 20 times
in my career in the first [ __ ] 16 i
was sleeping on a futon
the last three times i had a bed and a
one-bedroom apartment
i finally have a [ __ ] house right
finally feeling like a success he's
gonna come and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] way i was joking this week on
stage that the hole in the ceiling it
looked like
just imagine if a grizzly bears like
parachute didn't open that's was the
size of the [ __ ] hole
and i don't know why i think grizzly
bear i just remember seeing one fall out
of a tree
one time when they shot it with
something you know a tranquilizer gun
and uh just kind of came down was like a
big ball of fur that's what it looks
like
maybe a maybe a black bear i'd say
i don't know people you know the whole
time i bought this [ __ ] house the
entire time i've been fixing this
[ __ ] thing
and it's all been [ __ ] you can't see
plumbing
electrical i don't even know what else
the [ __ ] roof
just [ __ ] you can't see and i was
finally getting to the fun part
[ __ ] you can see the floors right [ __ ]
you can show off to people when they
come over
finally get a room done and mother
nature's like oh look at old billy boy
he thinks he's got a nice house there
let's let's let's do this i'll hang
a [ __ ] hole in your ceiling how do
you like that
you like that no you want some more you
want some more there's a little [ __ ]
glass of water
deal with that all the way down to your
basement all right there you freckled
[ __ ]
how do you like that so
i've been absolutely uh i don't know
you know it's um it's you know it's a
typical story typical story
man tries to do something takes two
steps forward
gets kicked in the balls and falls three
steps backwards
typical typical story and evidently
there's going to be some comedy in this
at some point but i realize it's tragedy
plus time and i'm still in the middle of
the [ __ ] tragedy oh you know what
else is great because the walls are so
old there's asbestos in them
you know like one percent so now the
people who are going to take the plastic
out today are like well we're not trying
to do that we don't have the proper
filtration system available
so now they're out right they're looking
at the [ __ ] downstairs they go we got a
test for lead paint it's like it was
made in the 20s you know it has lead
paint probably has 14 coats of it
under [ __ ] 36 that were painted on
top of that
so oh god
i i just you know i swear to god
i swear to god first i hate to say this
the first time ever i was in my garage
today
and i just and i actually quietly said
to myself
i hate this house
ah jesus christ do you guys say that
about your kids
does that ever happen every time you try
to make your kid a better [ __ ]
citizen and every time you think he
[ __ ] turned around
the stupid [ __ ] comes home you know got
into a fight at school he got caught
with a 12-pack or something and just
like i just wish i never had that one
should have stopped at the other one
or maybe skipped this one i don't know
anyways this is the monday morning
podcast everybody and
uh but you know something i am
uh [ __ ] it i'll i'll say something
positive in a second let's get into the
uh advertising i got to hype something
for a good buddy of mine will silvince
who was nice enough um to be part of the
um the group of comics that helped to
honor patrice o'neill
at the benefit we had and uh will was
one of patrice's great friends and a
roommate of his
um god they lived together at least five
six years so anyways will made some
t-shirts we sold most of them
at the benefit he still has some left
and i know a lot of people wanted to be
a part of the benefit
and you also wanted to help out uh
patrice's family
um well here's your opportunity to get
some limited edition patrice o'neill
t-shirts ones that are left
uh you can go to www.i'm better than you
dot com
and i'm better than you uh the arm
there's
no uh [ __ ] what is it an apostrophe
whatever that thing is between the i and
the m
it's all one word all lowercase i'm
better than you
and you with spelt just the letter u dot
com we'll put the link up on uh
the podcast page um just know when you
buy those that they're limited edition
and also you'll be giving money
to teresa's uh his mother and his family
all right there you go so audible.com
everybody
everybody every day everybody
audible audible is the internet's
leading provider of spoken audio
entertainment
information and educational program
programming
content from audible is downloaded and
played back on personal computers cds or
ipod players
audible offers over 100 000 hours of
audio programs from 270 content partners
that include leading audio book
publishers broadcasters entertainers
magazines and newspaper publishers
podcasters and business information
providers
listen whenever and wherever you want
just like
the podcast you are listening to right
now audible has over one thousand
science and technology
and over 1 1100 science fiction and
fantasy titles with more being added
all the time audible has over 100 000
titles to choose from
every genre genre audible
has it covered ah man i'm a [ __ ]
get a free audio book download when you
sign up for a free
trial today you know we should do that
me maybe i'll be better at reading out
loud
go to www.audiblepodcast.com
bill to get your free audio book today
all right so there you go well here's
here's the positive thing
that i take out of um
out of what happened to me oh here's one
thing that
you know you know when your life is is
messed up something bad is happening to
you is people bring up the fact that you
still have your health
that's usually a good sign that
something horrific happened to you
but um actually seeing that story about
that guy
[ __ ] dying in that sinkhole was one
of the creepiest things i've ever seen
in my life and i was like okay
all right i'm sitting here crying about
some wet floors and walls
was i swallowed up by the earth you know
so i don't know i guess that's that's my
positive way of looking at it by them
bringing that
horrific image into your head the [ __ ]
is wrong with me
um did i mention when i was in grand
rapids michigan i had a waffle
witch i did say that right what's a
waffle witch you ask it's a sandwich
made out of a waffle
with scrambled eggs and bacon and
cheddar cheese in the middle of it and i
still think i'm paying for it but
you know something it was delicious i
gotta tell you
i did enjoy that waffle witch um
you know what i'm not even gonna [ __ ]
around i'm gonna get right to emails
here because this is something that's
been
bugging me said uh emails red is dead
billy ready two shoes uh they said that
by 2060 all redheads might be gone
also the greeks believed redheads turned
to vampires after they died
thanks and good luck all right
the key word and that is they say i
guess that's words
they say that by 2060s by 2060 all
redheads might be gone
do you realize how [ __ ] dumb you have
to be to believe that
all redheads are going to be gone by
that's literally 47 years from now
i mean granted by 20 in 2060 i'm gonna
turn 92.
i'm an old [ __ ] right now i'm 45 years
old this year by 2060
i will be 92 years old but that's that's
possible
i mean if i keep eating waffle witches
and having my house collapse on me i
imagine that's going to take a toll
all right for all you [ __ ] morons out
there
who hear that in a bar or read it on the
internet and you just keep repeating it
without even thinking of what's coming
out of your mouth
how many little redheaded boys and girls
have you seen go to the mall
they're [ __ ] two three years old
you're telling me they're all going to
be dead before they're 50
you're dumb [ __ ]
they're so [ __ ] dumb some [ __ ]
said it was a recessive gene
and by the time it went around the bar
we were all going to be dead in 20
minutes
and people are so [ __ ] dumb and they
just repeat what they hear
that they come at you when they say dumb
[ __ ] like that do you realize how many
people have said that to me
i mean at least this guy was smart
enough to at least put it to 20 20
60.
i mean look if we're all gonna be gone
we're [ __ ] taking you [ __ ] with us
because
unless you guys just like if the next
hitler comes along
and he just really hates [ __ ]
redheads and starts to eat but even then
there's gonna be one of those schindler
list guys who's going to make a list of
us [ __ ] redheads and we're going to
survive
right and then we'll have a museum of
tolerance for [ __ ] redheads
and then the history channel will slowly
stop showing holocaust stuff
and try and balance it out and show some
redhead genocide
you know and then there'll be some some
uh
steven uh ready redberg will make some
[ __ ]
movie and get a bunch of awards and then
the howard stern of then will make the
analogy like i tell you all you got to
do if you want to make a
[ __ ] win award is make some sad
movie about the redhead genocide
let me tell you [ __ ] blondies you
brownies you blackies
all you [ __ ] blackies that didn't
sound good
i was talking about hair oh jesus all
right
we're here to stay all right don't ever
us to me
i don't estimate the [ __ ] heart of a
redhead
okay that's why your hair's red that's
that burning passion in us it's not the
devil
it's because we're better than you we're
a select few you know what i mean you
know what you guys are you [ __ ]
blondes brunettes all you [ __ ] you got
you guys are you like the [ __ ] ford
taurus
you go down the highway there's a
[ __ ] zillion of you maybe once in a
while you see a testarossa
all right a nice freckled one
has that ever been done has anybody ever
been had a [ __ ] swagger about being a
redhead
um all right one last little
advertisement here really quickly
legalzoom.com everybody
it's national start your business month
at legalzoom.com
okay i know i've been talking about this
for more than a month but so many of you
are starting businesses right now
so legalzoom has decided to stay to
extend it through march
this unbelievable offer call it whatever
you want just remember this is a great
time to start your own business
whether you're setting up an llc an s
corp sole proprietorship or a non-profit
legalzoom takes care of you from start
to finish their award-winning service
was developed by the best legal minds in
the country
and every business gets personalized
attention that's why over ninety percent
of legalzoom customers would recommend
the service to their family
you'll be in good company three dozen
companies of the i
the inc 500 list were started through
legalzoom start your business
right at legalzoom.com legalzoom is not
a law firm and provides self-help
services at your specific direction
but there's so much more now every llc
in a corporation package includes easy
to use business accounting software
a 269 dollar value for absolutely free
be sure to enter bur bur in the referral
box at checkout
start your business protect your family
and safeguard your assets at
legalzoom.com today
all right back to the podcast here
yes so for the love of god can you
people stop
and just think you know all right you
know what redheads any redheads out
there listening
just say to them just go like do you
realize how [ __ ] stupid you are right
now
huh oh whatever who gives a [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] that's not my goddamn cause
you know what i can i can guarantee this
right now i'm still gonna be around in
and i'll be out there climbing that
[ __ ] rope and i'll have the last bit
of lead paint and asbestos out of my
house
and we'll see and then you guys will
technically not read it anymore because
all your [ __ ] hair fell out and the
[ __ ] on the side of your head is
is white
then that might do me in and i'll be
like ah [ __ ] and i'll [ __ ] grab
my chest
clutch my little freckled heart and i'll
keel over and you know what you know
what you guys will do
you'll [ __ ] laugh because
in your core you're a [ __ ] all right hey
bill
okay i want a boyfriend here we go oh
jesus here we go
bill i want a boyfriend hey bill i know
you're proud
you probably just read the subject and
went all we'll drop your panties [ __ ]
now i would never do that that's if you
said you wanted to get laid
um so anyway she says that's not quite
the case
um i'm a guy oh the left turn
the left turn i don't need to read this
oh wait he's only a freshman i was going
to say how is a guy do you not know how
to get a boyfriend at this point
half the sitcoms are based on gay guys
at this point aren't they
was that was that [ __ ] statement as
dumb as all redheads are going to be
dead by 2060 i don't care i got a hole
in my [ __ ] house
he says i'm a guy i'm a freshman in high
school and i like guys i'd consider
myself
i consider myself average pretty good at
sports
and decent with the ladies he said i'm
still in the closet
uh yo gay guys [ __ ] slay it
you guys [ __ ] slay it you know if you
wanted to
if you wanted to i'm telling you
you know what it is because you i don't
know i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
this you give a [ __ ] about clothes the
way they do or you want to watch the
same [ __ ]
that's the thing about gay guys you guys
want to do the same [ __ ] women want to
do
so hence you're around them and next
thing you know your dicks in their mouth
if i could just keep i could have just
kept my [ __ ] mouth shut
you know during dirty dancing and ghosts
and all those things i would have done
much better when i was a younger man
but whatever this isn't about me this is
about you let's plow ahead
he goes i go to a public school and
there aren't many gays
well not as far as you know um i don't
want some
fabulous guy just another normal guy
like me
i like that you don't want him to be
like sitcom gay
walking in a room going oh my god
love it
[Laughter]
are there any gay guys like that at this
point um anyways what advice could you
give someone in my position
maybe your lovely girlfriend has an
opinion thanks bill i love the podcast
and go [ __ ] yourself
you know what i might even call nia in
for this one hang on a second let me put
this [ __ ] thing on pause
all right the lovely knee everybody can
you just close the door by the way
there's a [ __ ] because the goddamn
fan trying to dry out the walls come
over here we don't
we only have one microphone our [ __ ] is
all over the place so i don't even know
where the hell the other microphone is
all right all right so here's the deal i
feel like we're singing back up for
somebody right now
um this dude wants a boyfriend he's a
freshman in high school
uh he's still in the closet slaying it
with the ladies
he doesn't want some fabulous guy he
just wants another normal guy like
himself and he said what advice could
you give someone in his position
maybe your lovely girlfriend has an
opinion thanks bill love the podcast oh
and go [ __ ] yourself
so he's in the closet but you want to
meet a guy
jesus christ what did i just say what
did he just say no but i'm trying to
like take in the situation
i mean first of all i feel like if
you've been drinking you have wine on
your breath
yeah i was drinking champagne in the
other room it's four o'clock in the
afternoon
um i think i mean
i first of all i think you should maybe
not necessarily come out of the closet
to everyone
but you have to sort of go where the
gays go
and i don't mean just bars and stuff but
there are certain like restaurants and
like areas that are
you know heavily you sound like you're
giving like a powerpoint
a powerpoint like presentation and like
and you have to
go where the gays go you should just
written that down on a chalkboard the
thing is i think
it's a little bit problematic that
you're still in the closet you are free
to come out whenever you want to
you shouldn't have pressure time out
shut up time out but i'm saying
when you're when you're out of the
closet it makes it easier for you to
meet other people and get into a whole
little groove and you meet people
and they invite you places here there
and everywhere and that's how you start
to meet people
but if you're still like why no no you
can't but when you're still in the
closet
there's going to be that secretiveness
and that sort of
sneaking around and hiding and ducking
in corners and you start getting into
situations that you don't want to be in
as a closeted gay person because i feel
like any
gay person who's lived their life in the
closet trying to date secretly
will tell you no we'll tell you that
it could lead to not so good situations
so i feel like you should probably come
out in a way or at least just start
hanging out with other gay people
i'm gonna have to start having an
orchestra start playing when your answer
goes
if you want me on here to answer
questions i'm going to answer them the
way i answer them i don't need you to
tell me when i don't need anybody
telling me how to answer them snap snap
snap
you asked me to come in here if you're
just going to like micromanage how i
answer the question
what is wrong with you you know you're
an angry drunk
i'm not drunk couple of glasses of
champagne you turn into an [ __ ]
i don't think you should come out
not as a freshman for [ __ ] sakes
people are such
[ __ ] you know what i mean i think he
should just i think he should go find
some other college he's a freshman in
high school
oh in high school high school you know
[ __ ] just
ride it out find some other gay kids
hang out with them play baseball
down at the uh the gay baseball park and
uh
but you know once you become uh you keep
watching you know what you need to do
you got to leave your [ __ ] town
behind then you move to a city
does your high school not move to a city
let me finish my ignorance you don't
move to a city they'll have the the gay
part of town and it's going to be over
the thing is because a lot of high
schools are gonna have abs
a lot shut up a lot of more progressive
high schools they'll have like an lgbt
you know club or something like that
this he obviously doesn't have that or
he would [ __ ] join
it he went he's going to a high school
like i went to a high school
you know get back on d right it's a
[ __ ] meathead school
that's what's going on with him those
morons aren't going to understand them
why why go through extra [ __ ] pain
the great thing is he knows who he is
and he knows the direction he's going
you're gonna be fine
uh i would say try and stay in shape
because you are trying to
appeal to a bunch of guys and we're all
[ __ ] uh
you know i just don't want him to start
cr trolling around
online getting sucked into some seedy
situations
where older guys are going to take
advantage of himself because he's young
in the closet and he's very you know he
doesn't quite know what to do
i just i'm worried that he's going to
get sucked into that type of [ __ ] as
opposed to trying to find peers
where you're all sort of going through
it together that's why i was encouraging
to come out of the closet or to at least
maybe start affiliating if you're if
your high school has one of those lgbt
clubs
or whatever you know that way you you
feel less alone so you're less likely to
like i say
go online and get sucked into some weird
head trip
sexual abuse situation because there's
nothing like an older predator
no that an older predator will love more
than a young confused i'm still in the
closet wait a minute no not
so you're saying older gay guys are
predators i'm saying there are older
people who will
prey on young young well listen 50 year
old guys will try and bang an 18 year
old chick
so why would why wouldn't somebody's
saying we're all pieces of [ __ ] what
kind of
hatred are you spewing i'm just saying
i'm trying to bring the world together
he's in a very precarious situation and
if you start going down that road where
you're just
sneaking around so much you can get
caught up into some bad
[ __ ] and i don't want some older guys
saying oh [ __ ] he's getting blown by
[ __ ] chicks
this guy's killing it's like he's
hitting from both sides of the plate
so are you bi no he's still in the
closet but he's killing it with the
ladies
well you need to stop that right now i
don't know he doesn't good for him
it's just going to be another chapter in
the book i think you're going to be fine
sir
then i think it's podcast it's on its
way everyone on twitter i know you guys
have been asking me for weeks
what's going on with the podcast what's
happening is i'm also rebuilding are you
fighting with your record label what's
going on
why is this project keep being delayed i
know i'm rebuilding my website right now
and it's got my films on and it's got
some writing that's
your podcast room is underwater my
podcast room is underwater
my sanctuary is destroyed but that's why
it's taking so long so bear with me you
guys
but um you should do you should do a
podcast underwater in a flooded room
just like kanye west he had a busted jaw
he still went in the studio
where you going all right all right all
right
well listen we were just [ __ ] around
there i think the great thing is that
you already know who you are
so you're going to end up where you want
to be
um that age just really isn't easy for
for anybody
but uh i will tell you this all of all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] she said
she's right about those creepy old gay
guys looking for a young confused young
man out there
you know you're better than that all
right you gotta have some standards
no white chest hair beat it old pubes
all righty plowing ahead
what do we got here dilemma hey bill
would you rather be permanently
invisible
under the condition that inanimate
objects you've touched
also become invisible jesus christ
or would you want to be able to
shape-shift into anyone or anything in
the world
but you have to stay that way for 24
hours
oh without a doubt shape-shift i mean
how lonely would it be if i was
invisible and everything i touched
became invisible
i wouldn't want to do that you know
would i want to do that how could i
bring down these [ __ ] international
bankers if i was
invisible then i could make inanimate
[ __ ] invisible oh that's what i do i
touch a bunch of guns and give them to
the regular people and have them go down
to one of those [ __ ]
devils islands meetings um no i wouldn't
do that [ __ ]
no i'd be a shape-shifter now the real
question is who would you shape shift
into
troy aikman you know i'd commentate a
game right out of the back
you know right out of the gate to see if
people could notice i have i have some
of those gloves that he has you know
those
i'm an adult guy gloves now the ones dan
marino used to sell
i got one of those long it's wintertime
coats and sometimes i wear a suit
you know kind of coach i could stand
there with [ __ ] earmuffs on
uh what would i sound like them
who'd i shape-shift into that's a
[ __ ] weird one
oh i you know what i couldn't handle
that power because then basically if you
could shape-shift
all you'd have to do is shape-shift
into any girl you ever wanted to [ __ ]
whoever she's [ __ ] you just
shape-shift into that person you just
come walking through the door
hello you know with some flowers
oh my god i'd be the first person
brought up now what kind of rape would
that be
the shape-shift and rapist
you know and then they'd have to somehow
how would they stop me from
shape-shifting myself into the foreman
of the jury to say
we the jury find old billy rape his red
face not guilty on all charges oh my god
they're that big jesus christ
um
although being a shape shifter would be
great
man you could freak the [ __ ] world
out
you know it'd be great if some like huge
leader of the world
was was given a speech and you somehow
got behind them and were also on tv
jumping up and down you know like
somebody who painted their face except
you look just like the guy giving the
speech
you know oh that could be endless
[ __ ] fun
how would i handle shape-shifting oh
jesus there'd be a lot of conversations
with a higher power
with that one you know like when you
drink and then you get sick and you're
like oh god i swear to god i'm never
going to do that again just let me get
through this i swear to god i'm going to
clean up my [ __ ] act
like what do you say to god after you
just shape-shifted into your neighbor
and [ __ ] his wife
[Laughter]
god if you can find it in your heart i
mean technically you know
she doesn't know she's none the wiser
and i know it was wrong and uh
i'll say a couple of hail marys
i promise i'm i i will not shapeshift
into anybody today
that's all i mean i you know some that's
one of those things when a after i died
and god's given me that you're going to
hell look now i'm just going to be like
dude
i mean come on i could shape-shift
all right half the people on earth can't
even handle becoming a bouncer without
being a douche i could
shape-shift would you think i was going
to turn into [ __ ] ronald mcdonald and
push some kid on a swing
all right there were some hotties that
lived on my block
and uh some other guys got to him before
i did and i should have been man
enough to accept that but you know i had
this uh
get out of jail free card so i
shape-shifted into him when they were
uh away on business
and i would just come home surprise home
a day early
and then i [ __ ] him and i left and
then i
let her deal with the weirdness the next
day when her husband came home
when he came home a day later hey i'm
home how are you
what do you mean you're home where where
were you
yeah i thought you were just in the
bedroom and then he's like what what the
[ __ ] going on
jesus christ you know something i
thought they had made every porno that
you could make
that's a whole new shape-shift in porn
shape-shifting porn discovered right
here on the monday morning podcast
um all right what the [ __ ] else am i
getting that's all the emails i had this
week
that's all i got ah for [ __ ] sakes you
know what
you know something you know what he's
even worse i didn't watch any [ __ ]
hockey this week
i watched nothing i didn't even get to
enjoy the [ __ ] boston bruins
winning three to nothing sean thornton
beating the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ]
ronaldo guy what the hell his name is
i missed all of that i missed all that
because i was i was on the road again
you know it was a great gig too i did
the fountain street church for laugh
fest
out in uh grand rapids michigan and what
was phenomenal about that was
i got to perform in a church i got to go
up on the pulpit give a little speech i
had a great time
you know it was amazing it reminded me
of old tiger stadium
um because
old tiger stadium was one of the few
stadiums that was the only stadium major
league that had an upper deck that went
all the way around
and this church had an upper deck
that went all the way around the church
from one side of the altar all the way
to the other and then the altar was up
there
and uh i don't know made me feel like i
was in an old ballpark
all right let me see here oh okay
okay here we go
oh [ __ ] you know what i'm doing right
now i'm trying to i'm like so i can fill
out the rest of this podcast i'm looking
for uh i'm looking for emails
this isn't good this isn't good to be
doing on a live podcast somebody text me
you think
bottom is good could he do this in six
inch in a s
in a six inch stiletto all right
oh sheila e yeah sheila e kills it
i still think i still think bonham's
better than sheila e come on
you know plus john bonham was he was
sort of a fashionista he used to wear
those silly little boots all the time he
could still [ __ ]
he could still kill it what is with
everybody always trying to [ __ ]
well i guess he's the benchmark right
um although sheila is the [ __ ]
all right here we go i found an email
i'm just going to start randomly reading
these right now hey bill
i'm an avid fan of your podcast as i
listen to it every monday with my
chemistry
tutor who is now a fan of yours as well
well jesus you guys aren't getting
anything done are you um i have a
question to ask and forgive me if i give
you a history lesson but this is
something i want to get off my chest
holy [ __ ] is this a long ah come on
people try not to get things off your
chest you know how bad i read
all right let's give it a shot you know
what the first thing i'm going to do i
want to make it larger
all right it's kind of personal for me
but you as a man might understand
and i'm not saying a woman would
understand better because she probably
would never understand at all my problem
i am a loner and i have always been i
relate to that sir 100
we are on the same page i never made any
friends as a kid and i was abandoned by
everyone i knew
all right now you just went into the
[ __ ] now you sound like you're in
um now what is it hands christian
anderson
what's the name of that guy who wrote uh
not toy story what the [ __ ] is it called
their uh christmas story christmas carol
something christian christian leightoner
and i can't
[ __ ] think um ghost of christmas past
part two anyways i don't know anything
about my family members because their
name
besides their name and job title over
the years i started to hate everybody
i came into contact with every person i
met i'd be condescending towards
and i was indifferent towards everyone i
met
a few years ago i had this girl try and
become my friend which is weird because
i keep to myself
and nobody bothers me but all of a
sudden this girl comes up to me and
starts asking about who i am
i of course tell her to [ __ ] off
jesus christ dude because i tell her to
[ __ ] off and i'm cold and indifferent
you're not indifferent
you have a definite feeling towards her
[ __ ] off
uh she rode the same bus i wrote and she
tried to make conversation with me a lot
but still i was just telling her to [ __ ]
off but not in those exact words oh okay
all right
but uh i told her to go talk to someone
who cares
dude how old are you every time i looked
at her she always smiled at me
the smile was the most amazing smile
i've ever seen in my life
if a smile was a super yeah you [ __ ]
had a crush on her
if a smile was a superpower it'd be hers
and i couldn't help but
melt a bit every time i saw a smile out
jesus christ dude what's going on here
a few years ago i got into every i got
everyone in the school coming up
to up to me asking who i was
a few years later turns out that she was
asking everybody about me for two years
and nobody could tell her anything about
me
so now she's gotten the whole school
interested in me and finding out who i
am
dude is this like a fantasy or does this
really happen do you wear like a leather
jacket and ride a motorcycle
um they never learned anything about me
now that i am in college i am starting
to see her everywhere
dude can you just [ __ ] this girl or take
her out for a malt already
come on man this is a critical part of
your life
you're young this girl's you're still
you're drafting in the first round
you don't want to wait too long you wait
too long to [ __ ] find a mate
all of a sudden you know you you're
trying to find some [ __ ]
once in a lifetime six round pick you
know
like a tom brady it's not out there um
he goes anyways when we actually meet
it's awkward and she just stares at me
uncomfortably then runs away
i don't know why this happens to me
whenever i think i see
what i don't know why this happens to me
hear or actually run into her is there
something wrong with me
why am i going through this weird bouts
of fight or flight mode
dude because you were [ __ ] abandoned
by everyone around you
which hurt you as a kid so now you're
trying to [ __ ] wall yourself off you
should [ __ ] talk to that girl just
tell her say listen
you gotta understand i'm a psycho i
didn't have anybody in my life
i don't know how to do this but when you
smile at me i almost fall out of my
chair
can can you handle the fact that i'm
socially
a little far behind my peers
and with that would you like to go see a
movie okay and then every time you feel
like sabotaging it
just i don't know
i don't know dude that's that's you're
gonna have to undo like 20 years of [ __ ]
it sounds like now i don't know if you
can do
if you can do this uh
you know in one week you know like those
dumb dr phil shows
you need to come out of your shell and
everybody claps and then you go and like
the guy's supposed to be fixed
it's gonna take a while but dude you
know something
you should definitely go after this girl
if you're feeling stuff like that you
should definitely do it
and uh she sounds like she's you know
socially uncomfortable too
so you know you can help her she can
help you
both you guys you get a little more
outgoing next you know you might you
might have something there
and if not at the very least going
through that experience with her
we'll give you a couple at bats so when
the right one comes along you'll know
what to do
all right there you go good luck to you
sir
um all right what are we up to here
ah 49 minutes it's [ __ ] dragging i'm
sorry guys
this is why i never do podcasts when i
fly i stink
i i never should do podcasts when i fly
and i come home
and there's a [ __ ] hole in my ceiling
right
is that bad oh here's one
hey bill you're being ripped off there's
a video out there called staking a bj
day no you know what i ripped them off
i actually read about it and i forgot i
read about it and i said that they
should be staking a [ __ ] day this
right there is why i don't watch other
comedians
x because [ __ ] just flies into your head
throughout the course of years and years
and years
then all of a sudden somebody asks the
question you give the answer and you
think it's yours and it's not
um stake in a [ __ ] dad i did not come
up with that somebody else came up with
that so i am not
i am not offended this is like you guys
listening to me just read my junk mail
isn't that what's going on right now can
somebody please explain to me how the
[ __ ] montreal canadiens are in first
place
how do those [ __ ] suck and they're
still good you just at this point
you just have to give it up to that
franchise they're just a good [ __ ]
franchise
but you know something the [ __ ]
pittsburgh penguins
pittsburgh penguins all of a sudden
they're coming on you know what but
those [ __ ] those [ __ ]
they
always they like every time
they went for mario lemieux then they
got yarmouth yaga
right then they had a little bit of a
lull there
then they got old rosie red lips and
they get geno
and then he also had [ __ ] uh what's
his face that they just traded to the
hurricanes
i can't think of anybody's [ __ ] name
and then you think like okay that's it
it's over right
how many [ __ ] times they like the
[ __ ] hockey version
of the new york yankees from the 1920s
to the 50s
where it was ruth garrick to dimaggio to
mantle that's what they're doing
in hockey i don't know
this is my thing as long as the montreal
canadiens continue
to suffer in the curse of patrick wah
you know and they know it's a curse
that's why they try to make friends with
them again
because they realized after they booed
him out of the city that he went to
[ __ ]
colorado and started winning them and
they're like we don't need him
montreal blue blockade rouge right they
didn't give a [ __ ]
now they give a [ __ ] now all of a sudden
they're asking them hey
you know we're kind of uh you know a
little sorry
it's [ __ ] phenomenal and every year
that goes by
more month old montreal canadian fans
die
and less of them know what it's like to
win a cup
and i gotta tell you i [ __ ] love it
you know what i love about montreal
canadian fans you know what they say to
me now
they bring up gila floor that's how
far in the past that's how far in the
past anything great happening
between them and the bruins are they go
[ __ ] ape [ __ ] when they beat us now
in the regular season
you understand they owned us gila floor
[ __ ] gila floor scored that goal before
i even watched my first [ __ ] hockey
game
i don't know how old you people think i
am that was like the late 70s
i was too busy recovering from being hit
by a car
i didn't have to recover i got two days
off from school i do remember that
happened on a wednesday
and the guy said all right you know what
you shouldn't go to school thursday
friday and i was [ __ ] psyched going
for once i don't have to fake sick
and i sat there and i i watched cartoons
and i ate with a little spoon
hate with a little spoon because the
bumper hit me right on the side of the
head
i've done this before in the podcast put
two fingers right on the side of your
head right
and then bite down on your molars your
back teeth there
you feel that thing that goes in and out
that's right where i got hit so it hurt
to chew
so they i had to eat with a little spoon
for two days and i couldn't go to school
one of the greatest things ever happened
to me
this is cj7 i believe um
big [ __ ] guy getting out of it oh my
god i hit him i hit him oh my god
i totally [ __ ] drove right into the
guy i didn't look i thought i looked
there's another guy saying stake in a bj
day uh
um is spreading this had nothing to do
with me
it had nothing to do nothing it's not
mine
it's somebody else's all right here we
go last thing i'm going to read that's
going to mercifully be the end of this
uh
podcast bill thought this might interest
you it's an article about divorce this
guy's an illustrator
tough road to hoe um i am too
three years and still no settlement and
the guys broke as a result and has
stopped producing work in hopes
that the parasitic x will give in once
there's no cash flow
oh and the guy is predict prodigiously
good as a painter
yeah you know i think i actually have
faith in some of these divorce
settlements
that um i think in the near future
there's going to be way more
way more light shined on these things
and
uh
eventually it's gonna it's gonna come
around
you know can't there be a uh
i just i don't get that that [ __ ] where
you can just
it's just too one-sided with one person
could just live off the other person
i've talked about all this [ __ ] a
zillion [ __ ] times haven't i
you know that whole [ __ ] where uh the
woman starts dating a new guy but she
won't let the guy move in because her
last guy made more money
so then the two of them just sit there
living off the [ __ ] first guy
you know you don't think that's [ __ ]
up
well i do um all right you know what
people i tried i tried
you know i did my best i tried tried to
do a podcast
um i think that's it sinkholes water
damage hockey small towns eating like a
[ __ ]
yeah i gotta stop doing that guys i've
really let myself [ __ ] uh
it's weird i look good with a shirt on
but with a shirt off
it's not a uh it's not a good thing like
my chest
is 35 but my [ __ ]
now who the [ __ ] is this is this going
to be another guy telling me i got
asbestos all right
all right this only give me 55 minutes
this week people i apologize i'll give
you an update next week you know what i
owe you guys five minutes and you will
get those five minutes
next week okay that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves
um i'll talk to you next week
you